i'm in swindon it is not the most
picturesque city in britain but what it
does have is this the magic roundabout
and yes britain's you will probably
already know about this but americans
i'm guessing you're gonna find that a
little bit scary five miniature
roundabouts around one central
roundabout that goes the wrong way now
if you want to look into the history of
this and how it came to be then the
central british road database has a good
run through the history of how the road
research laboratory came to make it but
what i want to talk about is the idea of
emergent behavior because most of these
drivers have no special rules for going
across this they're not working out a
plan in advance they're following simple
rules avoid collisions
follow the lines give way to people
already on the roundabout and point
towards your destination
like birds a few very simple rules can
create a really complicated flocking
behavior even if each of those
individuals doesn't know what's going on
if you want to know more about that have
a look into buoyance made by craig
reynolds started in 1986 complicated
flocking behavior generated in a
computer from very simple rules follow
those rules here and you'll pretty much
safely get where you're going you don't
need to plan in advance you don't need
advanced driving skills or to have done
it hundreds of times before you just
need to follow simple rules the same way
that flocking birds do emergent behavior
means that this very odd roundabout here
hardly ever backs up even at rush hour
it's a triumph of road design although
they will probably never be any built
like it again the magic roundabout here
in picturesque it's windham